[Music starts] [Audio Description - not captioned]
[Lisa Federer, PhD] Data Science basically
is just the set of methodologies and techniques
that are used to extract knowledge from data.
So, how do we get from a big pile of raw data
to something that's actually meaningful.
[Maryam Zaringhalam, PhD] Part of making data
available to so many different audiences is
really building that scaffolding, that infrastructure,
for people to find data and then ultimately
make use of it.
[Federer] NLM has been involved in data before
data science was even really a term.
We have the National Center for Biotechnology
Information, which is a really incredible
data resource for people that are working
with biomedical data of all different types.
And we have a lot of other resources that
we make available, like PubMed, to provide
access to the literature.
So really, we have been involved in making
information and data available to people for
a long time.
[Zaringhalam] We're in this moment where we
have genomics technologies and we have wearables
that are collecting information from us.
We have computerized clinical records and
all of these different data sources
that, if we could combine them and figure out you
know what are the best forms of analysis,
we can really accelerate the speed of biomedical
discovery.
[Federer] And we have the kind of expertise
at NLM that allows us to, not only make data
available, but do research that really advances
data science.
Particularly in the areas of things like natural
language processing, which involves using
data science techniques to extract information
from text.
[Zaringhalam] When we think of a library,
we sort of think of books on a shelf and librarians
as people handing books
to us.
But really, NLM has this long track record
of making data available to different users
in all of these different types of ways.
[Federer] Like any library, we exist to make
information available to people. And
now, we're doing that in a way that fits
with the modern techniques and technologies
that we have available to us through data
science approaches.
[Music]
[Music fades to silence]